pas de base légitime ce sont les mots du
ministère américain de la justice au
sujet de l' enquête sur michael flynn un
vrai coup de théâtre dans ce dossier qui
empoisonnaient la maison blanche depuis
2000 17 mai que lui et est il reproché
exactement michael flynn était accusé
d'avoir oeuvré en faveur d'une collusion
entre l'équipe de campagne de donald
trump et la russie pendant la dernière
campagne présidentielle américaine
en d'autres termes il aurait été
l'artisan d'un rapprochement entre
moscou et le candidat à la maison
blanche donald trump
de quoi alimenter le discrédit du
président américain chez ses opposants
démocrates qui parlent d'ingérence
étrangère dans l'élection
mais jeudi dernier l'accusation prend un
sérieux coup dans l'aisne le ministre de
la justice des états unis
williams bar estime ne pas disposer des
preuves nécessaires pour incriminer
michael flynn pour enfoncer le clou
les auditions menées par le congrès sur
l' enquête sont déclassifiés
elle montre que les agences de
renseignement n'ont jamais disposé d'une
preuve quelconque de collusion entre
michael flynn et la russie donald trump
s'en félicite lui qui a souvent qualifié
ces accusations de chasse aux sorcières
orchestrée par ses opposants
hier c'était au grand jour pour la
justice aux états unis félicitations au
général fluide et à bien d'autres
le plus gros crimes politiques de
l'histoire américaine et de loi sydney
powell
l'avocate de michael flynn va plus loin
dimanche dernier elle affirme que barack
obama lui même étaient à l'oeuvre pour
piéger son client en cause notamment une
réunion à la maison blanche en janvier
le tout a été orchestré et planifiée au
sein du fbi haye lors de la réunion dans
le bureau ovale ce jour là avec le
président obama
donald trump parle désormais d'un obama
gates le principal intéressé a réagi à
la faire il n'y a aucun précédent que
l'on puisse trouver sur une personne
inculpée de parjure qui s'en tirent
impunément
c'est le genre de situation où l'on peut
commencer à redouter que notre lecture
habituel de l'état de droit soit menacé
même réaction dans le camp démocrate
de nombreux élus évoquent une parodie de
juste
his flynn a plaidé coupable d'avoir
menti au fbi au sujet de ses contacts
illicites avec la russie ces mensonges
ne devienne pas maintenant des vérités
ce dernier rebond ne l'exonère pas mais
cela incrimine williams bar dans la
pierre dépolitisation du ministère de la
justice de son histoire politisation ou
pas ce dernier volet sonne comme une
victoire pour le président américain
donald trump remporte ici une première
bataille même si la guerre est encore
longue pour garder son siège à la maison
blanche